thank you date dig dig dig dig dig dig
how you like our intro welcome back to
the jillion podcast friends we are doing
our special guest Jake Walker and it's
Friday night so we are having to drink
out of our Jenna Julian podcast mugs
which you can get at Jenna Julian
podcast calm you know bug sink one
tastes better on geez they do yeah yeah
they taste more podcast see ya quick tip
if you want something to taste good just
make your own mug with your own logo on
it then even the drink sucks you feel
important something having priceless
advice I feel like my days would be
better if I had a cup that said my name
on it and I drank it hey your day is
better I'm witnessing it this is my name
this episode of the Jenna Julian podcast
is brought to you by I'm gonna go get
the protein bars are you serious right
now Jillian oh I thought they were like
in the other room BPI sports with their
new awesome gluten-free protein bars
this one is cookies and cream that one
is chocolate peanut butter oh damn I
love when you say it Jen mmm say it
again I didn't even say it all sexy like
that on purpose but that's like you have
the time how you talk you any mean for
it to sound so sexy but it does this
comes out on accident BPI sports guys
they have all your supplement needs they
have a whole line of pre workouts branch
chains and now they're gluten free
awesome protein bars guys these are like
really really awesome texture like
really like tasty things that you don't
really feel like are are healthy for you
but they are because they're BPI sports
so going to BPI sports calm and pick
yourself up some of these BPI sports
protein bars episode was also about to
you by movement watches the watch I have
on the watch Jenna has on and the watch
J does not have on what I wish I had on
yeah right movement watches guys this is
an awesome new watch company that has
sponsored the podcast guys
flawless elegant style these watches I'm
telling you when you go to their website
they look like they cost
a much smaller risk than items between
four and five hundred bucks but they
don't they are affordable starting at
1:15 check it out it's nice very nice
selection go to plan the MT watches some
gold on gold try that again
MV MT watches comm /jj for 15% off your
entire order thank you to movement
watches that's MV MT watches comm / JJ
this is nice - it's nice and yours um
shade Stark in here anyway so yeah they
go through she what I wasn't paying
attention to through shade I forgot I
forgot I forgot to hey why even bring
that up dog dog sleep she sleep now why
man up now dog my dog why didn't I know
um anyway we are here it's Friday night
where a manager in camera here is Jo our
jaywalker is our good friend we met him
through the internet which I love the
way we met it's very old-fashioned like
internet style we're like we found your
stuff and then um I think what happened
is we I was doing your thing in the vlog
right yeah yeah you you talked about or
you did a license-plate pronunciation
and your vlog and then I got a bunch of
comments they were like I'm here from
Jen and Joyce podcast knows how they
wouldn't find the vine yeah I was like
god I love that yeah the vine that we're
talking about a jade does these vines
we'll get to it later but he pronounces
license plates in his own like way and
it's pretty damn hilarious Jay has an
epic voice che is an epic voice thanks
guys
everything says life sounds better well
you guys can already hear it's epic um
anyway with its closing that um so
you're you're a Viner you're comedian
you're I guess an internet all things
internet personality and what's
interesting about you is you have a foot
in like the comedy door which is like
the real real comedy and you have the
foot in like the internet door what
you're doing a lot of both how did you
like when you made that crossover to
start doing internet stuff how did you
find your way to kind of maintain both
like be in both worlds I guess I mean
the Internet
stuff just kind of happened because my
friends and I were making weird videos
together and putting them on the
internet like I feel like it was the
most organic possible way for it to
happen and then opportunities kind of
started to present themselves and then
like my career stuff like the acting
comedy stuff helps the internet stuff
and the internet stuff helped the so
it's like I said biotic yeah sure that's
awesome yeah it's super cool and you and
your buddy Fitz yogi FETs which we
should have on the podcast awesome
beatboxer he's [ __ ] don't don't get
funny - well it's Rob he's not watching
he doesn't waste his time whoa hey you
said you said our podcast sucks this
week can we talk about that can we
address this [ __ ] shade I you know
she roasted herself this week and some
somehow decided that the podcast was
included you acted like you didn't know
that I didn't write that into this song
I didn't know until we were shooting
that is such a we were in the middle of
a podcast and she just says the podcast
sucks and first wiping the [ __ ] mean
to be fair I'm having a terrible time
with you guys so yeah you know what and
you're a terrible guest so my podcast as
so I'm a terrible person you know what I
hate you get out yeah so that was
actually an awesome video which I I'm
not gonna talk about too much because I
know you don't talk about yourself but
I'm proud of that video this week that
was awesome thanks that's not okay well
that's good talk do a funny video you
watch it yeah
oh hell yeah [ __ ] ugh so in addition
Cass doesn't suck is it it is a total
joke I think famous loved uh in addition
to your internet business and stuff we
were quite the rocket League team we
play a lot of
here's the thing it's not it's not even
that it's a lot it's just that we play
really well yeah hmm you know we just
thought [ __ ] up [ __ ] them up so
bad like half the time I'm just like oh
man I have so much guilt like I just
killed like 10 people yeah seriously and
it's like man these these people are
gonna have to kill first of all I get my
rug Li you can't kill people as you can
yeah yeah you can blow them up you can
destroy dragon hit the body are a sock
are well dare you you drive around in
place it is it car is a quick a rocket
on the back yeah that is the coolest
thing I've ever heard in my life we've
lost we've lost in total of maybe like
500 games it's like we lost one game and
it want the game that Jenner was in the
room for i watch you lose like 12 years
in a row I hope [ __ ] can you say that
how dare you yes so wearing matching car
outfits or what another change that was
[ __ ] we look like the Village People
of SOT cars suckers Chaka's soccer I've
never called it a sock car before that's
the name of the game though right it's a
car car that's not the name of the game
anything is in rocket we do it it says s
OCC AR Jenna's name works again what do
we do I don't know saw sips drink let
the moment pass brutal uh-oh where's
yeah that's what we're really good at it
yeah we're really good what we're saying
which is so much fun I haven't really
been into a game like Rockley yet as I
am right now and why I honestly haven't
either
it's it's really addictive anyway this
is not a podcast by buckling if you want
to catch that one twitch stream and you
guys feel like you hang out every day we
do know we really know you came over
today I was like oh like your face no
like 15 minutes before I came here we
you look long day over while we were
playing rocket like we just had to win a
game before we stopped playing yeah and
then I came over yeah um so you make
vines you also do traditional acting
stuff where you do the audition gig what
is it like doing the audition gig still
right now when you have like the Vaughn
I mean first of all like you're on vine
right now yeah talk to us about that
because obviously all your attention is
on vine because you have to like do a
bunch of other stuff yeah
I mean I feel like when I think of
something I'll put it on vine yeah um
like it I think specifically this year
like I shot a movie earlier this year
um you guys know that's right you went
to New York I was cool um congratulation
coin twice coin heist
are you allowed to talk about it I mean
I can say the name yeah okay it's called
cool
it's called coin heist uh I forgot the
question
one of yet what are we talking about
here [ __ ] me dude ah no I mean it's it's
just uh you are like you wearing a lot
of hats right now oh yeah which is no
it's interesting but it's cool that you
know you're seeing as relevant as you
possibly can on the internet while you
do everything it's super cool because if
I get tired or annoyed one thing I can
move on to another so if you don't see
me you can see me in a certain space for
a long time it's usually cuz I'm doing
something else it is super cool right
yeah I don't feel like you have to post
vines ya know which is a good feeling
that's like the depth of your creativity
showed you and you feel like you have to
do something yeah man yeah what do you
think about binary no yeah yeah it's a
platform changed a lot man I know there
were user bases down like a bunch but um
strangely I feel like by now is a lot
more like it was at the beginning when
people were just like I'm just gonna
post whatever the [ __ ] I want to that
makes me look like it's kind of gone
back to that play yeah for sure which i
think is really cool um it's the problem
is that a lot of people that downloaded
vine and then would watch vines and then
they deleted it because they stopped
watching it getting them back it's gonna
be super hard yeah yeah like oh yeah I
already know what vine is about and it's
bunch of shirtless boys yeah
shirt was cute boys it is nice a
shirtless cute boys yeah no that's
musically no that is music as your -
like five years off I and ten years off
on how do you read any voice acting
I've always want to ask you this I do a
lot of voiceover auditions so yourself
so I'm really super bad at you know like
a really [ __ ] extraordinary ward
that's shocking to me that someone to
bring you in for a voiceover audition
and be like no thank it's it's super
saturated the market is crazy saturated
um yeah I did a Burger King commercial a
few years ago that was pretty cool
that's awesome
superglue voiced it yeah that's cool
yeah that was the guys like when you go
in like for auditions like do you have
to bring a resume first of all I don't
know how it works yeah do you put vine
on it yeah well actually I just have
social media following my extra info and
you combine all the members of course I
combined yeah yeah but it's cool because
it's a conversation that I have with
caching right yeah yeah it's like super
cool people they're getting smart
traditional media people because I want
people with a following with a built-in
following yeah obviously and it's crazy
because there's so many people with
followings willing to just give it yeah
you know give it to you know to clients
and like I can do this but also I'll
promo the [ __ ] out of you you know
what's crazy to me how many people are
famous on Instagram now mm-hm like how
many people have a million plus
followers on Instagram yeah like
Instagram is their sole platform yeah
and they don't even do anything but like
take pictures with tea yeah true yeah
super hot they're also exam detox tea
yep if you beautiful you employed by
Instagram for sure period because that
tea will pay you is it good
I don't know I mean if it's supposed to
make you like look all skinny and hungry
regular teachers some of them have like
a light laxative in them so hmm don't
like detox as dark so it's active
serious guys can we make a company
called [ __ ] tea shitty Shi T EA yes GG
shitty shitty true there are so many
people that just do Instagram and that's
their life yeah I mean [ __ ] me I mean
[ __ ] is right that's crazy it is crazy
it's why I don't think everything's
moving at light speed right now you know
I really in two months things are gonna
be yeah even different I'm kind of like
older Instagram though I think it's like
boring now I get bored you're talking
about that the other day tell why is
this gonna burn you because I like I
like snapchat a lot and I like YouTube I
like Twitter just for informational
purposes like if you want to see
something like that's going on you can
look it up on Twitter let me get the
most up-to-date news the Instagram I'm
sort of like oh no I just scroll through
some pictures I'm like what am i doing
I'll give a [ __ ] it'll looked at my tag
pictures like people tagged me and funny
[ __ ] and then I just sign off I would
definitely agree with you the tag
pictures like the fan account fan at its
shout-out to all the fan accounts
they're awesome because they obviously
put you know time and effort into these
pictures and edits and stuff it's cool I
feel differently I mean I agree that the
interface is stale like it's just
pictures maybe a short video whatever
but I I like pictures you know like I
fall a lot of photography accounts a lot
of time lapse accounts like things like
that which I feel like I'm gonna go in
there for different things than I am for
Twitter or more for whatever else you
know like you find this game a lot not
really like it's a it's the lifestyle
platform yeah it's like hey look at this
cool dope life I'm living yeah I know so
I'm not even about that
no it's so edited it's like an amazing
picture of myself today thank you it's
like the last few like the last
remaining thing on like popular social
medias that is like super [ __ ] edited
all the time yeah you know what vine
like you eat after enough vines you see
what a person is like you see what they
look like you sure you know I mean
Instagram is always you can just edit
the [ __ ] out of it know what and it's
always like whatever you want you meet
them in person and not recognize them
yeah yeah that's correct out of that's
man Beach in deep [ __ ] [ __ ] to speak
in a deep [ __ ] we want you to read us
some [ __ ] license but that's that's
the deepest deepest [ __ ] dude alright so
Jay to this series of walk back this is
like my second favorite series you've
ever done crying loud
line where you basically we're driving
in traffic it was like stop traffic in
LA in LA as it always is and you found
license plates that you would like video
and then you'd read them in a really
[ __ ] awesome way and we were like we
died laughing the first time we saw it
so we like blogged about it and like I
said that's how we met but we've
gathered a couple license plates are you
ready yeah you can scroll you can take
your time and [ __ ] scroll through
room and [ __ ] hmm so why don't you read
it first I would actually is and then
let me see let me see
and if you need a second I like
California license plates okay for
whatever reason that is just oh yeah I
got one tell us what they are play
alright so this one is uh six w XZ five
six nine okay and I'm gonna say it's so
watch the zoo zoo Athena it's so much
this is really good we said that J
should hand people their license plates
of the DVD pronunciation at the same
time yeah oh man the Foxes walks - do I
like it because it likes they sound like
words sometimes yeah yeah look what is
this a walks it sounds like a dinosaur
like an animal yeah surprises here oh
man so walks a zoo did y'all see the
siwash the zoo's they're just such
majestic creatures
I love that you just did that right now
that's impressive watch so walks is ooh
um should I do another one yeah yeah if
you feel like it you're that's not a
browser that's why you can't scroll down
yeah it's alright picture got interest
beyond six dzg to six one
sodoes ago just take a one oh my god
doesn't go sick one like it's so dumb
and it makes me less so hard yeah it's
like one of those really really simple
ideas that like you never would have
thought was funny until you like saw it
and now it's [ __ ] hilarious I
honestly couldn't even tell you why I
started doing it yeah I was in traffic
one day and just like yeah how would I
say that it's just so [ __ ] funny
first time I saw I was like in tears
yeah that's what like I said that's my
second favorite series you've ever done
my first favorite is animals be like my
god I almost be like oh my god so good
so good it's like I'm not gonna really
like even try to explain it like go look
up all the animals be like on J's vine
will link all of J's stuff below but
check it out it's on a spine what were
you going to say they're actually all on
85th it the other on 85th okay I mean if
they're I really buy them yeah okay yeah
bullying bullying both well you say
though you don't post them unless he has
like a genuine laugh going right yeah no
you don't just post them to post up we
sit there and we'll be like what animal
can and then we'll just think of the
dumbest animal then when we start
laughing what was the first one this is
big snakes dude was a turtle after that
you turn minnows turtle yeah seriously
guys like some of the funniest farm
signs
ii and bull Jenica Szell Szell
I felt like gazelles was a little under
I was that's one of my favorite ones and
it like didn't do as well but uh welcome
to the Internet welcome to the yeah
whatever you big is really funny the
inner it's like [ __ ] this [ __ ] you [ __ ]
hey [ __ ] you for having you not you and
your whole existence I like what we say
we
personally disappointed in you as a
human why would you do this
I feel offended mm-hmm I am offended
what time is it bed hmm oh look at that
she checked her movement watch this
podcast is brought to you by movement
watches what a transition I was she just
did a transition I drove them I'm so
proud of myself
guys get yourself a movement watch
movement watch like like you look at
these watches they they they're
simplistic through they look luxurious
but they're affordable they start at
$150 go to em VMT watches calm /jj check
out their entire selection first of all
but secondly get 15% off your entire
order once you go to that URL because
it's a secret URL that only you can go
to because you're here watching so tell
your friends it's a [ __ ] seat
actually tell you tell your friends
please get everyone to buy movement
watches they're seriously dope though
guys they can be like party or OTD you
know say my god you're like I got this
one with the beige bed and I've been
rocking it like with my brown belt my
brown shoes do you match your belt to
your watch I try to cuz if I wear brown
watch I can't wear a black belt I've
heard that like I'll get shot for doing
unless you're in your jujitsu key like
all out I just went a huge stock hmm oh
man cuz your black belt the only colored
bag you can wear yeah that's that's a
good problem to have
I guess a good problem anyway back to
movement watch they're just gonna die
around and I walk in to remember these
guys guys go pick yourself up and move
and watch I'm serious like this is one
of the nicest watches I've ever owned
and it's like relatively at like very
affordable for watches that are in the
space check their Instagram and their
Twitter I will link it all below but
they have all their selection there for
you guys to pick from and like I said go
to em VMT watches comm /jj get 15% off
your whole order and then you'll be
styling with a new elegant luxurious
look and watch and all your friends are
going to you know want to be you up and
take it so learn self-defense and then
get moving
thank you two moving watches responds
with the podcast we appreciate you the
watches are dope also brought to you by
BPI sports there are new BPI bars
protein bars there's a real boy right
here so what you all want what do we
know what I want to try that on a
trolley that's the other day talking
about a chocolate with that peanut
butter chocolate so guys if you've ever
had like a protein bar you know that
like you're eating it and you're like
this is a protein bar it tastes like a
protein bar these I really desert talked
about it I want to talk about on your
Jade okay I just unbox it is embark for
eating it okay ETS gun it's got good
shade oh that looks like it it does
looks like a chunk like a chocolate bar
huh oh I like those sound of him chewing
into it sounds again like this I'm
really good it's really good guys 20
grams of protein 17 grams of fiber zero
trans fat and guess what they use stevia
so there's no real sugar in it and that
[ __ ] cool mmm gluten free like I said
guys so people like me and you if you're
gluten free cake I'm not so loose yeah
yeah you want a box you get a box for
having come to our house to be on the
podcast I'm winning today yeah I just
won the day
it's good 17 grams a fire guy this is no
joke these are [ __ ] dope ass bars and
like the texture is good like it doesn't
taste like a pro it tastes like a
[ __ ] desert you know I'm saying no
it's really good
it's their brand new line of bars guys
BPI bars calm or BPI sports icon get
yourself some awesome gluten free 20
grams of protein amazing tasting bars
right now say thank you BPI sports thank
you to our sponsors links in the
description as always J how'd you get
into comedy um I did this thing called
speech in high school
damn which is like you know Speech and
Debate like the big team it was like
that except instead of debating you
would get in front of people and give
speeches okay but there are different
categories like you think of somebody
giving a speech it's like hey I'm going
to convince you of why global warming is
bad
and here's some data points so that's
like one
category but then there was this whole
other thing called humor where you would
take like a book and make it basically
do a 10 minute one-man show with all the
different characters and you'd play all
the characters and it was kind of a
weird form of stand-up and it was the
first time that I got in front of people
and like learned that I love making
people laugh and uh I kind of got
addicted to it
and I start doing stand-up in college
and was your first time to his head up
where did you go to college first off
don't know like uh University of
Minnesota whoo we went there go Gophers
we did they're not there she spoke there
did you like she wasn't invited she
should win there and spoke he's like in
a courtyard man should I just started
yelling in - no way it was great you'd
probably be competing with a crazy cycle
preacher yeah yeah who's there every day
you know I brought my speaker's still on
it and handed out flyers
I really enjoyed Minnesota we were there
it's a good state
it's pretty awesome yeah winner pizza
loot oh my god
Oh Raising Cane's we only literally only
want to visit we went because we were
there for two two nights yeah two night
and we went through the first night and
then the second night we were like
there's not getting anything else like
this is too good I mean there's a like
there's a lot of other good food yeah I
follow like the Twitter account like
visit Minnesota and they like tweet out
all this like amazing stuff yeah I
worked for the st. Paul Tourism Bureau
as an intern you did like is it st. Paul
yeah that's what I'm talking about yeah
yeah yeah and it was who's I mean they
got the [ __ ] right in there just they
never want to do that it's people to
visit st. Paul sent emails no I did I
did I was like hey you gotta you know
check this out you were called emailing
people this is just like come visit a
city we gotta list the emails and I was
like
Oh ever heard of st. Paul yo don't come
in the winter but like most of the other
times so when you got it like you
started doing we have a game we're gonna
play in a sec guys by the way which I'm
really excited about when you started
getting into comedy when you like do
your first couple stand-up nights open
mic nights whatever like what was that
learning curve like because obviously
like there's a giant transition from
doing it once and enjoying the feedback
and stuff to actually doing it the funny
thing is I felt like I cheated because I
had this public speaking experience
before I was super used to being in
front of people like my last speech
thing was like that they had this huge
national tournament and me and my I was
in a like a partner saying I can't
really explain it but are we performed
in front of 3,000 people and it was like
and I loved it I loved ever so after
that it was like oh I'm in a room with
75 a hundred people that was like not a
big deal at all
that's crazy so I feel like my best me
in front of a crowd like it elevates you
yeah for sure
do you ever do any time have you heard
bomb - or how to crowd those not feeling
it open mics murder open mics or the
wars really they are the worst
I don't ever want to do that I bet I
used to go at the Laugh Factory
sometimes I'm the nights where it's like
experimental material night I feel like
you have to go there and laugh extra
hard man like encourage people sometimes
yeah they're just there to sit there and
be pissed off seriously what are you
doing they're just trying to see if it
works or not
yeah it's hard when you when you have a
room full of other comics / - Lee comics
they've been Len doing the thing for
years and years and years and they're
like still in the same rope mics it's
like yeah [ __ ] you know they're not
going to be the most receptive audience
there - mad - you're fresh new jokes for
real like I rescue Jess
like [ __ ] this new guy God but I did a
live show twice but it was with two of
my buddies it was it was like a jokey
Internet II thing we had already
established our internet following so I
didn't have to win the crowd over it was
nothing like you know stand-up comedy
and I don't envy that at all like it's
in my blood because my dad was a
stand-up comedian for like 20 years
something maybe even longer in Boston
you know that I didn't tell you no no my
dad was the Stampede in Boston for a
long time and he was really funny and he
has it obviously in his blood to be able
to like that's what he enjoys he was
good at that he thrived on being on
stage with people there obviously like
the more you do that the better you are
at handling that sort of pressure and
situational you know anxiety whatever
you want to call it I just I'm so
terrified of that like that's something
that I feel like I I would have one bad
experience and just never ever want to
do it again yeah I feel like sorry like
all the respect to the world for people
who can do it like it's crazy it's I can
say I can say for myself like I'm
comfortable being in front of people but
the whole joke writing aspect of things
is a totally different monster yeah like
I I more than anything have respect for
people that like right just stop five
minutes of solid material is so hard to
write does it every sentence everything
you say is a joke yeah it's either the
setup for a joke until you're just doing
that and then having an hour-long
special yeah oh my god that's just an
impressive skill it I agree I do you do
any even semi-regular sort of thing
where you get on stage and Duke I just I
hit mics lately and I haven't I haven't
done a real big show for a minute but I
should how come well cool she wouldn't
know no hey Jenna something legs you I
can hear you but I can't see where he
goes with the waist I'm sorry I'm hidden
today if you really wanted to
like a green-screen outfit alright so I
came up with this idea for a game which
if I say so myself it's pretty [ __ ]
great basically what we're going to do
is there's a lot of YouTube challenges
going around some of them are pretty
[ __ ] stupid but someone are good and
the really popular gentleman angry well
some of them are really stupid think of
the long a fun [ __ ] but really the
really [ __ ] stupid yeah maybe it
wasn't great I just obviously YouTube
did it right Julian like right in his
own YouTube is oversaturated with
challenges everyone knows that it's not
something revelation that's what I'm
just kidding it anyway I thought of a
game where we could all come up with
challenge like challenges that don't
exist but just the name of the challenge
and then the other two people have to
kind of guess what soompi know like make
something up for it yeah like your your
your there's no real chance there's no
right answer it's a do you think it is
so prompt guests second I'll go first
all right wet for me College wait for it
wet pork what Fork challenge J the wet
Fork challenge is where you have to
stick as many wet Forks to yourself like
India yeah yeah like as a human without
any other help you have to like hold as
many wet Forks against your body as you
can or in your body or in your body or
in your mouth or anybody who's how do
you count them like how do you verify
they're there I mean you got to show the
world you gotta pull you got a Twp st -
oh the world show the world show the
world you can also stab yourself I feel
like I feel like the wet part isn't even
necessary they just happen to be wet
probably
my version they didn't have in anyway um
sorry Jenna what is what what is wet
work challenge no nice to hear you we
haven't heard you this whole podcast the
wet Fork challenge is when you lay in a
bathtub hey friend throws in a toaster
with a fork in it mix wet fart challenge
wait for challenge Forks in the top so
it's plugged into the law but the fork
and the toaster and then he spit in the
bathtub where you at okay so she's
already gone there well we're gonna go
later yeah you win the challenge
I feel like this game is gonna go to the
it's gonna yeah so my thing of the wet
floor challenges I think you glue or
tape a fork to each of your fingers mmm
and then you eat a bowl filled with your
hand so if I give your hand but then
extend it to the 4x piece like a shitty
Wolverine yeah feeling really hungry or
a shitty Wolverine that's that should be
called a shitty Wolverine that's pretty
good all right sure you get all right so
no one wins this game we all just lose
so we lost the first one first one we
went on to the second round Jamie and
rapidly yeah what would I talk about
we've never lost look at our record we
have a 99.9% win percentage like to
check out the check out the rocket we
boards yeah
we're on the top we're sponsored by a
rocket leader I think yeah this episode
of the nones we might be hidden because
our scores were too good but it's
definitely on the top yeah I did it
banned us they thought we were um they
were like we're losing it yeah Jania huh
this shows what she knows girls at video
games alright I'm totally fine Wow
so [ __ ] stupid so much that this Jeff
man uh uh ready yep the but beard
challenge ah but with two teeth yeah
okay but beard challenge wait a second I
think the but beard challenge is when is
when you you walk out onto the street
with a really like popular Street like I
would say the Third Street Promenade
somewhere was a lot of people and you
pick someone out of a crowd who you
think has longer but hair than your
beard is and then you verify it on
camera oh God if if it were me I
wouldn't take a lot just like a
middle-aged forty year old dude he's got
longer as hair than I have on my face
because my beard is not on if I had a
long beard that'd be more interesting
selection process you'd have to go to
some weird but hair growing cult where
people grow their butt hair really
really long like I got all my intimate
damn longer damn girl
oh sorry at least I'm knocking it over
Jenna what is your guest
I think the bucket challenge is like
when you have really really really long
hair on your head hmm and then you tie
it in a ponytail behind your butt so it
makes the beard like I think superwoman
could do it because her hair is that
long back down to her butt so then you
just pull it around the bottom of your
butt put a hair tie in it so then it
looks like okay what happens when you
like move like a human moves like it's
not just gonna stay right challenges if
you can do it or not
so you need long ass hair and then like
a Kylie Jenner book or you could like if
you're like laying first I don't know
whatever do a backbend and so that your
hair does it but then make it look like
a beard on your butt fair enough
Martin either can do it or you can't so
we would be great at this channel know
I'm bigger guy yeah we're not for sure
you'd be almost as good at that
challenge as you are at rocket League
that's hard man Tony he's good at
roughly Tino we play together Rockley
all right what is the buffer challenge I
think that the buck beer challenge is
guys who can or or ladies who can braid
their butt hair into the rough shape of
the beard oh my god you know what you
don't like a lot of challenges like it
takes braiding skills but it also takes
like shoulder dexterity to get there it
also takes very long butt hair yeah well
that's a given
yeah you got to be a pretty hair yeah we
don't play this [ __ ] challenge if you
ain't got no butter
what's your next do you have one in our
should we just keep reading ours keep
reading yours might the toilet Mike the
toilet challenge my kite toilet
challenge Mike the toilet am i see your
mi ke girl whatever you want
not em I see like microphone might be my
toilet like the toilet Mike the toilet
challenge I already got okay it's if you
own a restaurant or a place where
there's a public bathroom you see how
long you can get away with having a
video camera in your public restroom I
said Mike Mike yeah Mike so a video
camera wait Mike is a video camera with
the video blocked and it just records
the audio yes I got my screaming around
the world until you go to gym oh my god
and then so so the title of the live
stream on YouTube is Mike the toilet
challenge and then once it gets shut
down you know that person got arrested
you know they won all right okay
I think it's an audio-only challenge to
see who can pee the longest damn that's
not bad that's pretty good that sounds
like a real thing that sounds like a
real challenge now the YouTube machine
will probably go towards yeah
what do you realize you're the fun fact
what is it uh regardless of how big an
animal is everybody pees for about the
same amount of time really the bed's
ready
what about like whales keeper about the
same amount of time well mutilate their
pee holes like that big so they like
they pee like four gallons nice ready
safe uh what the [ __ ] is your life true
fact I'm Jay Walker
all right we're given that new newly
acquired knowledge I will say that the
mic your toilet challenges when you fit
as many animals as you can into one
bathroom and my call therapies and
compare the times for science for
science mark that's right that was a
good one oh thank god that's good fact
like the toilet like the toilet Eunice
you nasty and get a manicure all right
Jen was nothing we should've brought
coasters I'm sorry I [ __ ] this up yeah
like I'm I feel bad I've ruined this
table this tables piece [ __ ] what why
it's not it's just like tips over if you
touch it that's the service okay the OJ
Simpson champ oh my god the OJ Simpson
challenge is to see how long you can
drive away from me Skinner car chase
it's Grand Theft Auto and right fit my I
think it's the most amount of white
Broncos you can find in rent for one day
just I put them all over say something
like get along the parking lot and then
I put on the YouTube header okay job we
got six and white Bronco Broncos they
probably discontinued that model because
of them I'm just kidding did you what
was there someone read about OJ Simpson
really did you see that [ __ ] you don't
tell you I did cuz that's why I thought
of that it was um he was considered for
wait was that the chair was a video yes
he was considered to be the Terminator
but then they thought he was too nice
yeah the people Lancaster y'all he's
Australian yeah hey you so nice yeah
he's so nice if you're a dead person
yes I just like acquire all the white
Broncos without raising any suspicion
like that's that another Samsung job I
think that's pretty good or he's pretty
good with years I was going to say it's
uh how many times you can brag about
getting away with a crime
oh sure were you before you get arrested
again oh my god like yeah that's yeah
that's the OJ sanction challenge you
guys go do that and tag us so we can do
it Nash's no I'm [ __ ] joking nobody
do that dead or sleeping challenge I
gotta go you go into the Petco or
another pet supplier you go look at the
mice of the hamsters of the fish and you
pick out which ones are dead and which
ones are sleepy I can go ahead and say
mine's like just that same thing but
worse what is it so you go to a
retirement home oh man [ __ ] you do the
same thing that's the invader they sleep
you just knock on doors actually don't
knock that would ruin the game you just
open the door very quietly and you guess
and then you try to wake them up hmm
like what's yours I don't think I can
Placido oh god yeah no no no that will
not eat you fired go take naps at like
graveyards and then people might think
you're dead but you're really seeking
that but I good yeah
just sleep on the ground you thought you
bugged [ __ ] probably you guys both why
didn't I think of any of these yeah we
did so Jake we all missed oh yeah yeah
how about the the angry neighbor
challenge yes I was in my time I don't
know all right
the angry neighbor challenge is when you
terrorize your neighbor to the point of
calling the cops on you and then when
the cops come to discipline you you just
say hey there's just such an angry
neighbor
hmm Jenna not impressed I was wrong all
right I say the angry neighbor challenge
is see how long you can get away with
stealing their mail until they know them
huh Jill you've done that before like
you just walked to their mailbox and
take their mail like hopefully they live
in like a house or something where
you're not supposed to be and see how
long you can get away with taking them
now it's not like a serial yes felonies
stealing someone or opening someone
else's mouth mmm no you won't open it
you'll just take it and babies are
committing a felony
yeah it's my mom but she was like open
something that came in the mail for me I
like mom that's a [ __ ] felony what do
you do me that's my mail [ __ ] all right
what do you think neighbors angry Nick I
think it's um I think as being as loud
as possible in your apartment and saying
how long you can do that for before then
your neighbors called police
mm-hmm yeah apical I have a lot of cop
related challenges I got some bad
neighbors man like some real bad ones
yeah my old place in Santa Monica is the
worst neighbor ever give me a video
about that yeah she was terrible okay my
name is final line loudly [ __ ] crazy
Yeah right look I used to listener have
sex all the time I'm like shut the [ __ ]
ah nobody wants to hear that it's weird
we share a wall how did you know that it
was like legit sex though hurt okay you
remember my townhouse the bedroom like
would open to like that little patio so
they were all the same so are like
bedroom ground-floor patios like you
look there's look a little crap like
we'd see in true to each other's patios
she would leave her [ __ ] bedroom door
open and have loud ass sex it wasn't
even like I could hear it even through
the wall it was like out into the world
she wanted people to hear that yeah you
should have parties like throw raves in
there like 5:00 a.m. in like a Monday
morning like [ __ ] no one is partying
right now go to work get rich good job
girl
oh alright we got next we got the sore
loser challenge hmm
let's go all right I got one ready yeah
just kidding I'm gonna think wow should
I go first or yeah okay yeah hide your
face you all know who your friends are
that are sore losers right everyone
knows that friend so gather all of the
sore loser friends you've ever had in
your entire life and then you invite
them over to your house to play a game
of rigged cards so it always huh I just
see what happens and film it also loses
genital sore loser challenge if it sucks
we can just move on I feel like this is
kind of a weak one sore loser challenge
go play baseball in front of your dad
until he gets mad at you for not doing
it good enough oh my god nothing to do
with anything
sore sore loser challenge adopt a child
raise it except for to teach it that
winning is losing to losing is so then
when it gets into like you know
elementary school sports all the other
kids are gonna think he's a huge [ __ ]
because he's gonna have the opposite
react my god such a great joke so and
then I would leave to YouTube challenge
oh my god I was good okay I got another
one I got another one here's some
artwork the extreme Face Swap challenge
my god okay I just think it's the
premise of the movie face-off
mmm that's what I was hoping for trying
to think ooh okay it's when you find a
wild animal you cut its face off and put
it on your face sorry I don't want to
cut any animals faces off here's the
thing for sure somebody in the world is
that
already I'm sure well they already put
it on their heads right yeah again
that's [ __ ] up
extreme pace often an extreme extreme
face it's when your Buffalo Bill and you
wear someone else's skin is your skin
extreme this was true face love it's the
love shot in this game
Oh two kids what is he getting from him
those are the [ __ ] basket yeah I mean
there's really only one answer for that
one yeah cut someone's [ __ ] goddamn
face off basically have you thought of a
challenge and I just wanted one extreme
right I got one more Jay you got one
more good one will end on that uh yeah
all right
hide and seek and kill challenge oh my
god why is that why are they so dark and
kill challenge the hide and seek and
kill challenge yeah the hide and seek
and kill challenge is when kind of need
a second you want me to hate you mine
yeah I didn't see you can kill
challenges you you organized a great
hide-and-seek game with you're like
really good rich friend right and you
all go to his house and you basically
play a big game of hide and seek in the
last person to be found wins the game
but since everyone's already together at
that point they've already seeked
everyone out they've already hid the
next thing to do is kill so they just
all leave the house and burn it down
it's the rich kids house oh so it's a
big-ass house well well I didn't say can
kill I think the hide-and-seek and kill
challenge is like a reality show I know
listen just that sounds good already
it's kind of like sushi bread except it
gets literally red where everybody just
gets on an island yeah and it's like The
Hunger Games oh why is it not exist i
watch that soap oh my god I want that
verifying it's a real live hundred
hungry games and there's only youtubers
on it yeah oh my god and then every
season youtubers just like die and then
one left survival fitness eight down no
I think the hide-and-seek and kill
challenge is when your brother gets in a
plane and then you hide and then if he
finds you then he shoots you with his
plane and then if he doesn't find you
then you get to shoot a grenade launcher
at him but then if nobody finds anybody
then you guys got to go to bed because
it's got your bedtime it's our plan
there's a plan
are we playing the hide-and-seek and
kill Shelly right now that's my [ __ ]
brother man he's ready to kill us it's
only brothers no sisters just brothers
because brothers and [ __ ] and
everybody knows that brothers are
[ __ ]
mother brother [ __ ] alright well well
done one of those sake was hard and
morbid morbid hey when we plan this out
we knew it was gonna go dark it was
gonna go darker just a matter of time
and that's what that's like that's kind
of way I have one that's left it's not
unless you guys make it to make it
[ __ ] up this what's your challenge
okay it's when you're chilling with a
hair tie in no makeup makeup domain with
sweat what hands on on weight it's a
sweat pants Challenger sweatshirt
sweatshirt okay and you said you know I
can always be the guy that you only walk
the halls until you find someone to give
you their sweatshirt so that you won't
be cold cold cold cold all right
cold cold cold so you can flaunt it hmm
sweatshirt challenge for me is your
sweater is a demon it has a mind of its
own and it crawls along the floors and
kills people at night so then you
I was thinking put a clapper on that
[ __ ] demon sweatshirt see what goes
down it's crawling through the holes
what do you think it is uh I'm gonna
have the default - demon sweatshirt mm
demon sweatshirt chromed through the
halls yo you want to go on business we
can make it a sweatshirt comedy called
demon sweatshirts like that sounds kind
of cool I don't sound good don't [ __ ]
take our idea guys I don't know it's
copyright and Trademark coca-cola -
that's what your challenge could also be
if you just walked up to people and sang
to them who you could get to wear your
sweatshirt like realistic okay what are
the stipulations of this how do you get
someone else to wear your sweatshirt
okay put a thousand dollars in it and
anthrax you do you know that one of my
relatives is one of the only people in
this country that have died of anthrax
no way yeah my dad tells me that all the
time my god yes so unlucky right college
eyes for that joke no but it wasn't like
you know the scary you know powder kind
it was like from uh he worked in like a
wool factory or something got bit by a
bug oh my god wait bugs have anthrax
something like that well the anthrax
bugs something I can't remember but like
there really aren't very many so Jim
comment vampire I don't know but he
really eat I'm dentist but it was you
know 100 years ago so don't feel weird I
feel weird I feel I'm uncomfortable I'm
sorry not because he wasn't making you
sweat he's making a sweater yeah there's
a big big difference one is anthrax I'm
sorry
it's not the sweater
yeah where'd you go I can't see you it's
just a floating head I like when people
I want to wear camo people are like if
you get dressed next time that'd be
great
does he like the I came out joking not
mine
mm-hmm Thursday yeah cool anyway J I
want to say thanks Big John for coming
on the podcast it's been a good time and
yeah fun and funny and thanks for
hanging out you guys are the best thank
you so much and me we will link to all
of Jays things below so you can click on
it and then be in Jays world he's a very
funny guy
and he makes mines and all sorts of
other things also I'm trying to figure
out how to get us like play rocket
League on the stream the other we should
do that have we got to figure that out
after though Xbox makes it difficult
with the chat thing and all that [ __ ]
but we do play locally all we can park
we can do that tonight bye guys for real
thank you for watching thank you for
hanging out guys we love you check out
our sponsors BPI bar calm and M VMT
watches calm frost JJ for all your
awesome awesome watch needs 50% off
there we'll see you guys next week for
another podcast and let us know what you
guys thought of those challenges and
what your definitions are cuz I'm ready
to check on the comments and see you
guys at upcoming [ __ ] go together you
guys are always killing it so we
appreciate you thank you very much
you